And I want to welcome you to the C.G. Jung Helpdesk meetup group. And I want to talk today about the topic of introversion and extroversion, which might be confusing for a lot of people because extraversion, like, people have not heard before. Most heard of extroversion. Funnily enough, extroversion is bad Latin and Jung said so.
That's why he said it has to be extraversion and not extroversion. Why can Jung be so sure about that? Because basically Jung coined the term.
The terms introversion and extroversion, or how we use it today, extroversion, is really made up, conceptualized, publicized, and made famous through Jung.
And Carl Gustav Jung was a psychologist and did a lot of research in a lot of fields, and he wrote a very profound book, and that book is called Psychological Types. And this was published roughly in 1921. And for the people who can calculate, Jung was born in 1875, which makes him 46 years old when he published the book.
And it's a very profound book because it's about personality. It's about the structure of personality. How we work and differ from other people in our personality. And what is personality? Personality is the experience of the world, but also the approach one takes to the world.
And funnily enough, the field of psychology that deals with personality is not called personality psychology, but rather differential psychology. Because in the end, personality is about the differences between people.
We don't really have an objective measurement for whether someone is kind or aggressive or very frightening, easy to be afraid. You're always afraid compared to other people. So if everybody would be incredibly afraid all the time, you would be then absolutely normal. If you would be around those people. People.
Similarly enough, every trait that we have for personality is always in comparison to other people. This is why it's called differential psychology. And he wrote that book because he already worked a lot with his patients for over 20 years. He worked with people with psychological problems.
He treated people with psychosis and schizophrenia and all kind of neurosis, depression, and so on. And he tried to create a work to help analysts to understand the patients better. And he said, this is very, very important part, to make the problems of the patient more approachable to the family.
Meaning he wanted to create a kind of language or concept to make it helpful for family members and friends to explain what is happening to their loved ones. And why they are the way they are.
So he created this framework of personality and created there something pretty profound because this is one of the best known scientific books known about Jung. And it is, for example, used as a basis for, uh, the MBTI, the Myers-Briggs inventory, and where it deals with, uh, sensation, intuition, thinking, feeling.
But also introversion and extroversion. Jung had a specific reason why he wanted to work on that book, and it was really to bridge differences between two of his peers of the time. So Jung was there right in the beginning of psychology when psychology really became a science. And there were, of course, other figures of great importance at that time.
And one person that can't be ignored is Sigmund Freud. And the influence that Freud had with psychoanalysis on culture, on psychology, and the popularization of psychology cannot be understated. Really one of the most important figures of the 20th century, uh, century.
And another contemporary of Jung and also former patient of Jung, which is Alfred Adler, who both had profound contributions. To psychology that both made a lot of sense, but both kind of disagreed with each other. And Jung said, huh, that's kind of weird. How can you have two things?
Because Freud is very often, he's, he says, okay, the foundation for everything psychological is sex and basically the, the incest instinct. And Adler said, oh, well, everything is about power. And both could treat patients, both would have success, both explain a lot about our psychology. But the one says, oh, it's all about this. And the other one says, it's all about this.
Both are right, but contradict each other. And if there's one thing that Jung really, really loves, it's the duality. If you approach Jungian work from the point of view that you have a duality, you have opposites at play, you're already on a very, very good path because Jung loves opposites, male, female, Logos, Eros, conscious, unconscious.
And so on, introversion, extroversion that interact with each other and play with each other. Jungian psychology is incredibly dynamic. The psyche is a constantly shifting, evolving, exchanging system. It's not something completely fixed. This is also why Jung says about personality that it's not fixed.
It's not that we are born a certain way and we have to stay that way all the time. But rather it's the starting point.
This is how we start in life and our development through our psyche is by incorporating also all these other sides and yeah, functions and possibilities and capabilities that we have inside of us, but yet not available. So dynamic psyche, uh, there's Jung, there's his work, and Jung wrote on this book for 8 years.
It's a very, very long time for Jung, and I have to say it's a very well-structured book for Jungian standards because Jung was writing in a very, very unstructured way. But this book is incredibly well-structured and it has something very nice in the back. It has a dictionary where he explains what he means with certain terms because he uses terms differently than us.
And incredibly enough. Introversion and extroversion, which we today understand more as how sociable someone is, how comfortable they are in social situations, which Jung also talks about, but he does not put a huge emphasis on that. He says, ah, there's psychologically something very, very different happening.
And this is rather an expression of what people really are, how they function, how they experience the world, how they are orientated. In the world, and he had a complete radio silence for 8 years. He wrote before Symbols of Transformation, that came out in 1913. This led up to the break with Freud.
Jung and Freud were huge fans of each other and supportive and friends, and Jung was supposed to be the successor of Freud, but Jung wanted to do his own thing and was too interested in religion and the occult. So it came to a breakup and Jung changed a lot of his life and yeah, used the following 8 years to write this book and the process of writing the book.
There's another book published about that where he talks to a friend of his who's also a psychotherapist, and this is called The Question of Psychological Types. It's the letters between them. And if you want to experience a needlessly aggressive Jung, You can read that book because he's very, very confrontative.
I haven't seen him anywhere this confrontative, and the poor guy is only apologizing. The other guy, his name is Hans Schmid-Guisan. So this is fun. And yeah, so this will be the basis for today, this book, and especially the first part of the book where Jung talks about the psychological orientation that we have.
Because he says similar how we have two hands and we are born with two hands and two eyes and two feet and so on. We always have a preference. We always like one side more than the other, which means not that one side is better than the other, but rather we have both and we should learn to use both.
This is where the dynamic part comes in, where we not say, oh, I'm introverted or I'm extroverted and this is how I am and I will always be like this. Jung says, haha, no. You have to develop and your life will be basically structured about that.
So there will be stuff happening to you that will force you into your other side, in your shadow side, in your inferior side, in the underdeveloped, undifferentiated side to become more like yourself, because everything that's in your psyche should become integrated. So in the beginning of the book, he does something which is very interesting and also very unusual for Jung.
He looks for historical parallels for views on personality because the idea of personality is not new. Jung did not come up with that. It's pretty clear that there's differences between people and that there was research into why people are different from each other and whether there's certain types that can be characterized.
So I already talked about Sigmund Freud and Alfred Adler. That had different views but were right on their, their own side.
And Jung said Freudian psychoanalysis was very extroverted, meaning it focuses very much on the external world, very much deals with, okay, where does the energy, the libido of a person flows into? And Freud very much looks outside.
Freud sees also that when influence comes into the person, into the psyche, that happens to the superego. And how does the superego get formed? It's the parents, it's the laws of society. So for Freud, the psyche is basically a little bit empty inside except for the id, and most of the stuff is coming from the outside.
So Freud sees there the psychological relationship between the person and its surroundings. Adler worked a little bit different with his ideas about power. So Adler rather tries to remove the person from the influence of outside things.
So he's there a little bit trying to downplay the influence of the outside and trying to kind of remove it. And Jung said, ah, that's kind of weird. One is looking more outside, the other person's looking more inside. And he saw this pattern popping up more and more often, again and again.
Jung, for example, was a huge fan of Nietzsche, and Nietzsche also was a professor in Basel, same as Jung. Not at the same time as Nietzsche lived before, but Nietzsche also has this duality between the Dionysian and the Apollonian view.
Dionysus, the god of wine, of dance, and of celebration, intoxication, is very much, as one might suspect, something more social, something more outward, something about incredibly intense experiences in the outside world. A lot of emotion, a lot of affect.
And in contrast to that, Nietzsche talked about, ah, there's other people that exist and they're more quiet, they're more reserved, they're more contemplating, they're more thinking. And this is associated with the god of Apollo. So this is where Nietzsche would see this duality and that people fall into two camps.
And Jung said, ah, this kind of matches also the views of Freud and Adler. And he goes further. There's another famous psychologist called William James, and he talks about tough-minded and tender-minded. Where he says, tough-minded people, they're very also looking in the outside world. They're very focused on the material. They're very working with their senses.
They're very much focused on details and facts and so on. And in contrast to that, the tender-minded person is more intellectual and very ideal. And they are working there on a different plane. They're working there differently.
So Jung goes there through a lot of people, even, uh, Schiller and Goethe and so on, and some others to say like, oh, there's a kind of pattern that we can see here. People talked about putting people in two camps.
So you're on one or the other and clustered around there certain personality traits, which is something completely normal that we still do today for any kind of personality model. And what Jung did, he called this extroverted and introverted.
And the reason for that, both are Latin terms, extra meaning outside, intro meaning inside. Is we live in two worlds with our psyche. We experiencing two things. Of course, we have the world outside of us, something that we have immediately now. So for example, I look at my apartment, right?
I see my couch, I see my kitchen, I see all the things that are here, all the objects, all the material things. But also I have a psychology that's inside of me. So they have pictures, they have sounds, they have certain ideas that come up. This is also where I have dreams. I don't have dreams outside. I have dreams when I sit down to sleep.
And he calls those worlds the world within, the psychological world, or the world without, the materialistic world outside, outer reality. And he says, oh, the things that I have outside, Those are objective things, and the things I had, I have inside, I have, they are subjective. Here we have to be careful. We treat those things very differently today.
He just says, oh, both have their validity. Both are real. Both have an influence on us. It does not mean objective real and subjective unreal. It's, ah, it's just an opinion. Jung has an interesting view on reality. He says. Real is what has an effect on you. So when you have a bad thought, of course the thought is inside of your head mainly, but still you might feel horribly.
You might not work and live and eat and sleep and have relationships normally because you have a bad thought inside of you. That doesn't mean that the, this thought is less real than the couch in front of you where you sit or the food that you eat. Or the car that you drive, just because you cannot touch it. It is real because it has an effect.
So we have to be a little bit careful here. Objective just means the outside world. Subjective just means in the inside world, the inner reality. So that also what we have outside are facts and what we have inside are ideas.
Again, not saying one is better than the other, but I wanted to give this to make some quotes of Jung more understandable because this is very often the problem where it's going about understanding Jung. He uses certain terms and has certain definitions for it, but he doesn't give the definitions. So this is what I'm trying to do here.
So we have the world without, uh, so outer reality, materialistic, full of objects, full of facts, and we have inner reality. The world within, which is psychological, subjective, and the world of ideas. So we have both. We exist in both worlds, but same as with handedness, our initial focus lies on one world first.
So when I'm a person who is very much focused on the inner world, the world of psychologically reality and the subjective and the ideas, I'm introverted. When I'm more focused on the outside world with materialistic things, with facts and the objective and so on, I'm extroverted. And for Jung, this is just what it means. This is the definition. Both worlds we live in.
It's just, we have a preference for one or the other. Same as where you have with our hands. So, but what does it mean? What does it mean when a person is that? Because for Jung, it's not only this. It's not only, oh, I'm looking rather in one place than the other.
But rather, he says it has profound implications on the psychology because this is where people apply themselves and where they invest time and attention, how they interact with the world or with their psyche, both being equally important and both being equally valid.
So he says, the introvert makes the mistake of always wanting to derive the other's actions from the subjective psyche of the extrovert. While the extrovert can conceive the other's inner life only as a consequence of external circumstances. So you have to put yourself in the shoes of the other.
When you're extroverted and you only look in the outside world, you're going, oh, people do something because the outside world tells them to, because this is where they put their focus on. Discounting and not paying attention to the inner world, which is more on the side of the introvert.
The introvert said, ah, people have like idea or thought or some rationale inside their head. Why they're doing something.
So it is that there's already huge misunderstandings between the two sides there, and also the misunderstanding that people have within themselves because people are extroverted and introverted at the same capacity, but with a focus on one. So this is already where people can kind of sort themselves in.
Another quote: Since immediate reactions are always strongly personal, the extrovert cannot help asserting his personality, but the introvert hides his personality by suppressing all his immediate reactions. Again, how's the interaction with the outside world? The extrovert wants to express his personality, the introvert rather wants to hide.
So when we go through the book of Jung and we go through the quotes and we go through the works and so on, we find there are certain characteristics, certain buzzwords, certain keywords that are used on a spectrum. And this creates a kind of comparison that we can use on the extroverted and introverted side.
So the extroverted Dionysian side, to say it in Nietzschean terms, and the Apollonian introversion side. Again, our duality with the extroverted person paying attention to the stuff outside, relationships, and the introverted person with its subjective factor inside.
And this means that an extroverted person has more openness to the outside world, being there more confident, more careless in that sense also. Always talking about themselves basically, and feeling there very well, being very relaxed, feeling very mobile, and being very active.
And the question is, why is that? And Jung says it's a sense of perception. He says for an extroverted person, the outside world is kind of dead, kind of static. It's just stuff is there, but stuff is not moving.
So it needs the extroverted person to change and to do something and to become active, to actively change something then in the world. This is why the extroverted person is so active. This is why they act there always, because they say like, oh, if I'm not doing something, nothing is happening. So this is where a huge drive is coming from.
And in contrast to that, the introverted person Says, oh, the outside world is way too alive and active all by itself. And I don't want it to be that active. I feel that it has an influence on me, on my subjective reality.
This I want to dim it down, cut it down, because I don't want to have my subjective reality and experience influenced or suppressed or anything. So this is where Jung says the interaction with the outside world comes from, and this social aspect that we have more in mind for extroverted, introverted persons.
It's more that the introverted person is kind of protecting its inner reality from outside influences. And this is then, of course, you looking less for outside influences, spending less time in the outside world, and building there less of a, let's say, personal connection to that.
And what I find very interesting, and I had to say, spoke really to me, that Jung said, oh yeah, how extroverted, introverted approach work is very, very different. The introverted person wants its work basically to speak for itself. It rather would not like to be involved with that.
Like, the introverted person wants to provide a finished product. That speaks for itself, needs no explanation from the person who did it, how it happened, all these different things. Rather, it's supposed to be there and for others to be evaluated, and the introverted person rather communicates through that than directly to that.
Also, the introverted person wants to experience the world more through a kind of reflection that it— the introverted person has. In their psyche. So there's influences coming from the outside, but the inside is more like a mirror cabinet. So everything gets filtered through the individual psyche.
While the extroverted person will talk a lot about the personal idea, the personal connections, or the working process and so on. Wants very, very closely to be associated with the, the works of labor. So it is the introverted person who says, ah, the outside world is way too alive. There's way too much stuff going on and it has an influence on me and I don't really want that.
And the problem that exists there is it is there then a one-sidedness. And this is very important to Jung. You are never just one thing. You start out as one thing and you should go into the other to experience there more parts of yourself. Because we live in both worlds, both worlds are important for us.
We cannot ignore one and just live in the other. So what I have now is a little story from Jung where he has an example of an introvert and an extrovert and how their interactions would play out. So he says, Let us suppose two youths rambling in the country.
They come to a fine castle. Both want to see the inside of it. The introvert says, "I'd like to know what it's like inside." The extrovert answers, "Right, let's go in," and makes for the gateway. The introvert draws back. "Perhaps we are not allowed in," he says, with visions of policemen, fines, and fierce dogs in the background.
Whereupon the extrovert answers, Well, we can ask. They'll let us in all right. With visions of kindly old watchmen, hospitable seigneurs, and possibility of romantic adventures. On the strength of extroverted optimism, they at length find themselves in the castle. But now comes the denouement.
The castle has been rebuilt inside and contains nothing but a couple of rooms with a collection of old manuscripts. As it happens, old manuscripts are the chief joy of introverted youth. Hardly has he caught sight of them than he becomes as one transformed. He loses himself in contemplation of the treasures, uttering cries of enthusiasm.
He engages the caretaker in conversation so as to extract from him as much information as possible. And when the result is disappointing, he asks to see the curator in order to propound his questions to him. His shyness has vanished. Objects have taken on a seductive glamour, and the world wears a new face.
But meanwhile, the spirits of the extroverted youth are ebbing lower and lower. His face grows longer and he begins to yawn. No kindly watchmen are forthcoming here, no knightly hospitality, and no trace of a romantic adventure. Only a castle made over into a museum. There are manuscripts enough to be seen at home.
While the enthusiasm of the one rises, the spirits of the other fall. The castle bores him. The manuscripts remind him of a library. Library is associated with university. University with studies and menacing examinations. Gradually, a veil of gloom descends over the once so interesting and enticing castle. The object becomes negative.
Isn't it marvelous, cries the introvert, to have stumbled on such a wonderful collection? The place bores me to extinction, replies the other with undisguised ill humor. This annoys the introvert, who secretly vows never again to go rambling with an extrovert.
The latter is annoyed with the other's annoyance, and he takes to himself that he has always known the fellow was an inconsiderate egotist who would, in his own selfish interest, waste all the lovely spring day that could have been enjoyed better outdoors.
So we see there by this example by Jung how those interact, and there's constant miscommunication and misunderstanding because they have a different orientation in the world. They have put a different focus on things, but also, and this is the important part, they try to understand people through their own lens.
An introvert will always try to understand people in an introverted way. But there's such people that work completely differently. They work in an extroverted way. The other way around also. This is where a lot of miscommunication and misunderstanding comes from, from Jung. And this is why he wanted to write the book, right?
Because personality and psychology shapes how we experience and act in the world. And that makes it very, very hard for us to communicate how we see the world because for us it's a standard. But also for other people, it's very hard then to understand how we see the world, especially when they have another personality.
So Jung tries to give this kind of framework to the patients to understand themselves and for the family so that the family understands the patients better. So as I said, the problem is really you have two sides. If you focus on one too much, the whole thing comes down. Jung sees there a balance in the psyche.
He sees different forces that have to be working together in a kind of harmony. And if one is way too strong and the other gets ignored, this creates problems. And the psyche will always try to balance this out. So if you're way too much on the one side, the psyche will create a countermeasure on the other side.
This is where a lot of, for Jung, psychological problems are coming from. Like complexes, neuroses, even hysteria, as people are fighting against the other side because the other side is very strange and foreign and frightful. Same as in the story, like, ah, I will never spend time with an introvert again. I never spend time with an extrovert again.
It sounds very confusing, very frightful, and people just like to repress it and cut it out. But you cannot run away from your own psyche. So it will pop up in dreams. In situations in your life, in fantasies, or even like in accidents that people can have. When you are not one with yourself, you will do mistakes.
And Jung says, oh, there's stuff coming up trying to get your attention and needing you to pay attention to the other sides of the psyche. So he says, there are two main attitudes which differ fundamentally, namely introversion and extroversion. Both are perfectly good ways of living, so long as they cooperate reasonably well.
It is only a dominating one-sidedness that leads to disaster. So what does it mean when something leads to disaster? He says, just as the introvert causes trouble by the violence of his passions, the extrovert irritates by his half-unconscious thoughts and feelings.
Incoherently and abruptly applied in the form of tactless and unsparing judgments of his fellow man. Because for Jung, just because you're not paying attention to it, to this other side, does not mean it disappears. It's still there, but it will act without you having any say into it. Meaning it's autonomous. It has its own agenda. It has its own goal. It has its own energy.
So it will kind of bite you from behind. So he says for an extrovert, he will struggle psychologically because he's not really paying attention to that. For an extrovert in the Jungian sense, they don't believe in invisible forces of the psyche and having influences on people because everything is explained with the outside. People act how they act because of the outside.
So when you fix the outside. You fix the people inside. But Jung says, no, no, there's another side that also needs to be taken care of. So when an extrovert is basically denying or ignoring his psychology, saying, ah, it's not there because everything is outside, all this stuff happens automatically in the background, having an influence on them.
Meaning, I see half-conscious thoughts and feelings, which means undifferentiated, unsophisticated. Unreflected upon, creating then of course trouble again with the people outside in form of judgments or very bad relationships. So what is also outside for Jung is a persona.
This is a mask that we wear outside to the world where people interact with us. It's a kind of how people perceive us because they cannot perceive our complete psychology, as same as we cannot perceive it. So people have an idea about us even before they know anything about us. And this is a persona, a kind of role, a kind of expectation.
When you're a doctor, people will have a certain expectation towards you. If you are a car mechanic, people will have certain expectations towards you. And you kind of have to live with that because this is part of you, even if it's the expectations of other people.
And he says the danger of when you only look outside is that you might come identified with your persona and you think you're nothing but your persona, again, ignoring the psychological. So he says extroverts and all people who are identified with a persona hate to be alone because they begin to see themselves. So people become associated with their persona.
People believe there's nothing but the role that they're filling out in society. There's nothing but how other people are perceiving them because again, everything is outside, right? So this is the truth. This is where everything is.
And it's interesting to see that people are also outside with other people because they do not bear their own company to be alone with themselves, to perceive themselves. Again, this is a scary part. This is psychological part. That's the inside world. And I don't know about you, but I know a lot of people who can really, really not be alone.
They constantly have to be with other people. They constantly have to do things. Being alone, spending time all by themselves, is pretty frightful. And Jung goes there into the why that is. So how does one-sided introversion look like?
Jung says, the introvert is more conscious of his shadow and accordingly feels somewhat inferior. He cannot meet reality directly. But has to meditate over it first. By this mechanism, he avoids many pitfalls, but he also misses a great many opportunities. So when you shy away from the outside world and its, let's say, riches and possibilities, you miss all of that.
And he says, when you're very, very much aware of your psychology and psychologically minded, You very quickly also encounter your shadow. The shadow being the parts that are not you, but that are kind of expressing themselves in the psyche. This is a dark part, the unsophisticated, inferior part.
This part is very much associated with doubt, either that you're living doubt or you're experiencing doubt. And he said, this is way more true for the people who are living in the world within, so the psychological world. And this kind of course can have a negative influence on them because they're too much ruminating on that.
And if you only stay indoors, let's say, this is not where all this stuff is happening. Maybe today with the internet, but this is 100 years ago in Switzerland. I think there was not so much stuff happening indoors. And another quote, as a result of the ego's unadapted relation to the object, for desire to dominate is not adaptation,
A compensatory relation arises in the unconscious, which makes itself felt as an absolute and irrepressible tie to the object. Because this is the ironic thing in Jungian psychology. This is what I meant with just because you're on one side doesn't mean the other side disappear.
The extroverted side of an introvert will express itself in an inferior, automatic, Undifferentiated way. So suddenly the introvert will become very, very much obsessed with certain objects in the outside world that have an incredible influence on them.
So there can come then very obsessive behavior about things that normally are not in the sphere of the introvert. But this is also why he's unsophisticated there, because he doesn't venture out so much in the outside world or interact with the outside world in the same way as an extrovert.
So way easier caught by the objects that are there. The more the ego struggles to preserve its independence, freedom from obligation, and superiority, the more it becomes enslaved to the objective data. Meaning.
When you not pay attention to the other parts of your psyche, you are prone to fall victim to them. They do not disappear. It's just like you don't notice the influence that they have on you. And it will be incredibly strong influence.
But this is not necessarily a negative thing because for Jung is the psyche becoming aware of itself, becoming aware of the parts that are not you. Jung saw, for example, in neurosis, not really a negative thing. He said the neurosis is actually a positive thing because you become more introverted, you pay more attention, and you reflect more. You even get like tied down.
Yeah, you may not want to leave the bed or the couch, but it's a kind of healing mechanism in the sense of you are forced to contemplate. Freud had the same view, by the way, also. That similarly how when you get a fever, it's not the virus that is a fever. It's a reaction of the body to the virus to kill the virus. That is the fever.
Meaning the neurosis and the depression that is then there is coming up of certain contents that have been suppressed and that have not been processed yet. And they come to the forefront. They come to attention and they need to be reflected and processed on. That does not mean this is easy.
It does not mean that it's fun, but Jung says this is a natural process, which of course has to be supported by a therapist, for example, or by friends or by family or someone who is then supportive in these moments. But, and that's much, it's normal. The same as then for an introvert to fall prey to objects or the extrovert to fall prey to certain ideas.
That are not really thought through is then also something very, very natural. The problem is always being stuck. This is why Jung put such a focus on the dynamic part. That psyche is something that dynamically shifts all the time.
The problem is when something is completely fixated and does not move and does not change, then it becomes a problem because then there's this buildup that calls for compensation. And this is then where it needs to be broken up. So how does one recognize the other side, the introverted and the extroverted side within oneself?
And he says, the extrovert cannot see it himself, but the people around him, if observant, will always detect the personal purpose in its striving. Hence, his golden rule should always be to ask himself, what am I really after? What is my secret intention?
Because this is the thing, an extrovert, when he says, oh, I'm just being influenced by the outside world, oblivious to his own thoughts and ideas that might have a negative view on the world and have their own agenda.
It's a little bit like in The Lord of the Rings, you had, I think it was Théoden, which had the advisor who would whisper like bad thoughts and ideas into his mind, it would be like this, being uncritical then of the negative things that come and the counterproductive things. So again, what am I really after? What is my secret intention?
What is my psychological motivation to do something? Not the outside, but the psychological reason to do something. The other, the introvert, with his conscious thought-out intentions, always overlooks what the people around him see only too clearly.
That his intentions are really subservient to powerful impulses, lacking both aim and object, and are in a high degree influenced by them.
So interestingly enough, the introvert, by being reserved and being more abstract and being more intellectual, might then show bigger expressions of emotion, stronger impulses, and being driven by those, and being very strongly influenced by the things that are around them without being able to recognize them and acknowledging them.
So the observer and critic of the extrovert is liable to take the parade of thinking and feeling as a thin covering that only imperfectly conceals a cold and calculated personal aim, whereas the man who tries to understand the introvert will readily conclude that vehement passions are only with difficulty held in check by apparent sophistries.
Nice word, Jung. I guess that means like a complicated argumentation. But yeah, and we can do that for ourselves. Of course, it's helpful with others, and this is something that Jung always stresses.
The psyche and our psychological development does not only happen within ourselves, which is something that an introvert might think, but we are really dependent on other people and the relationships with them because they are more proficient in these other parts.
They might be more extroverted, they might be more introverted, and seeing them act and explaining their world and giving feedback to us from their point of view. Teaches something about ourselves as long as we are open to that.
So this is a point that Jung stresses very, very often, to be open, to be wrong, to be humble, to recognize that one is insufficient as we are right now, and to develop and become more ourselves. We need to have an openness for that and work on that and reflect on that. This is a psychological journey.
That people then take in their life to also watch the other side, to see it because it will come up all by itself, want it or not. And yeah, so to summarize today's event and bring it all together, it is that our personality is a dynamic system that takes place in the psyche.
It's constantly changing, it's constantly moving. And we have to pay attention to these moves and we kind of have to follow them. We have to roll with them as like the waves. So we also have a preference at birth, meaning we are a certain way, same as in a card game. When you draw your first hand of cards, it doesn't mean that this is a whole game.
It's just where you start and you should not be completely fixed on those cards. But rather realize that there's a lot more to explore in the game of life. And it is always that the rest cannot be ignored because it will make itself apparent to you and your life. And it's better to, yeah, be aware of that and then move with that.
So he says unknowingly, the extrovert and the introvert are already doing the right and correct thing for their psychological development. He says the two types are opposed in a remarkable way. The one shapes the material out of his own unconscious idea and thus comes to experience.
The other lets himself be guided by the material which contains his unconscious projection and thus comes to the idea. So you always encounter the other. It does not matter where you spend more time. You will find the one or the other either way.
And I want to thank you for your time and attention and your interest for today's event. And if you are interested, I did earlier events that go in the same direction or go more into specific topics. For example, I have an event on personality. It's called Typology and Personality.
Jung also had these thinking, feeling, sensation, intuition functions. I haven't talked about today because I talked about them quite a lot before. So I can recommend that. There's episode 7 in the podcast. There's also more on shadow. That's episode 56 on A Shadow of Doubt. It's a really, really good event.
And There's one on individuation, which is a psychological journey that one takes, and that was episode 15.